20 million Soviet citizens died at his
hands for a quarter of a century he
ruled his huge empire with a ruthless
iron fist terror was his modus operandi
while he was alive no one not even his
closest family members were safe yet at
his passing he was mourned as the savior
of his people in this week's Bond
graphics we uncover the terrible truth
about Joseph Stalin a single death is a
tragedy a million deaths as a statistic
[Music]
the man who would come to be known as
Joseph Stalin was born in the small
Georgian town of Gauri at the time
Georgia was part of the Imperial Russian
Empire his date of birth was December
the 18th 1878 Stalin's father
vissarion's urkesh Villa was also known
as Bey so he was a shoemaker
Oren's also an alcoholic who spent much
of his time away from home producing
footwear for the Russian army on his
rare appearances at home he would beat
his wife and son Stalin's mother
Ekaterina also meted out punishments on
the boy but was generally protective of
him
Stalin only learned to speak Russian
when he was nine years old and
throughout his entire life he never lost
his strong Georgian accent Stalin he was
raised in an atmosphere of violence
Gouri was a rough town with organized
street brawling being a popular pastime
on February 13th 1892 the young Stalin
witnessed the public hanging of two
criminals the traumatized child came
away with a hatred of a Tsarist regime
Stalin he was sent to a church school
where he excelled academically he sang
in the church choir and impressed his
teachers with his intelligence and his
memory in 1894 he graduated two years
ahead of schedule then at the age of 15
he was awarded a scholarship to the
theology Seminary in Tiflis the Georgian
capital however the teen was more taken
with the writings of Marx and Engels
than the Bible declaring himself a
Marxist and an atheist he joined the
Russian social democratic Labour Party
or our SDLP
in 1899 Stalin was expelled from the
seminary as a result of his Marxist
leanings by now he had adopted the
revolutionary pseudonym koba which was
the name of George and Robin Hood type
figure for the next two years he worked
as a clerk at the Tiflis meterological
observatory during this time he became
involved in organizing strikes and
writing articles for socialist
newspapers he also became skilled at
making revolutionary speeches in 1901 he
relocated to the Georgian coastal town
of Pitou me then he was encouraged by
the rsd LP to stir up unrest he helped
organize a strike in an oil refinery
which led to him being imprisoned for
this he spent 18 months in jail and was
then deported to Siberia
over the next 12 years Stalin he was
arrested six times each time he managed
to escape and return to the West often
traveling on forged documents he was
arrested for the final time in February
of 1913 and was exiled to Tora hansik
the most inhospitable part of Siberia he
was there for four years these years
they hardened him and they made him
cynical in 1906 Stalin married his first
wife Carlos Venezia their son Yakov was
born the following year Stalin was often
absent busy inciting unrest as a result
his wife and sons or little of him
karthik died of typhus in december of
1907 at the age of 22 at a funeral
stalin declared this creature softened
my heart of stone she has died and
wither have died my last warm feelings
for Humanity Stalin ignored his son who
was brought up by his in-laws in later
years Stalin ordered the arrest and
execution of much of Carter's family
including her brother Alexander who had
introduced Stalin to karta in 1911
Stalin fathered a son by his landlady
while living in a remote Georgian
village the boy Konstantin never had any
contact with his father in 1903 the rsd
LP split into two factions Bolshevik and
Menshevik Stalin was an admirer of the
writings of the revolutionary Vladimir
Lenin and aligned himself with the
Bolshevik cause his work to undermine
the Mensheviks and his involvement in a
number of burglaries to raise funds for
the Bolsheviks brought him to Lenin's
attention
Lenin was impressed with Stalin calling
him the wonderful Georgian in 1912 he
appointed him to the Bolshevik Central
Committee it was at this time that
Stalin drops his Georgian alias Koba and
took on the name Stalin meaning an of
Steel the outbreak of war in 1914
accelerated the collapse of Tsar
Nicholas the seconds rule to think on
the Eastern fronts and the large loss of
areas of territories Germany along with
food shortages and economic hardship
took its toll on Russia's fragile
infrastructure protests and strikes grew
in intensity over the next three years
and finally on March the 15th 1917 the
Russian parliament the Duma forced a
provisional government protests and
strikes they grew in intensity over the
next three years finally on March the
15th 1917 the Russian parliament the
Duma formed a provisional government
that same day Tsar Nicholas abdicated
the 304 year Romanov dynasty was at an
end a year later Lenin ordered the
murder of the entire Romanov family the
provisional government the Socialists
mainly the Mensheviks now ran the
country the dual power was necessary as
the government needed the support of the
Soviets who felt unprepared to take on
full power Stalin he was still living in
Siberian exile during the revolution he
returns to live in Petrograd where he
took over the editorship of the
Bolshevik newspaper Pravda which means
truth the Bolsheviks were a minority
party and Stalin decided to cooperate
with the provisional government in order
to bolster the party's popularity when
Lenin returned from European exile he
mocked the revolution and condemned the
new government as imperialistic and no
better from the old regime he censured
Stalin for his consolatory attitude
towards it as a result Stalin toughened
his stance not only against the
government but against other socialist
parties in July of 1917 protests against
the provisional government broke out
leading Bolsheviks were arrested but not
Stalin who was considered of little
importance Stalin hid Lenin and helped
him disappear into Finland in late
October Lenin resent Petrograd and urged
an immediate seizure of power
however moderates within the party
advised restraint Stalin surprisingly
sided with them
Lenin however pressed on on October the
23rd a meeting was held in which it was
voted to undertake an armed uprising two
days later the Bolsheviks armed wing led
by Leon Trotsky took control of
Petrograd
the provisional government was
overthrown the Soviets had seized power
Lenin instituted the new government the
Council of people's commissars Stalin
was appointed the people's commissar of
nationalities across Russia groups
opposed to Lenin's new autocracy joined
forces to remove the Bolshevik
governments as the Russian Civil War
broke out Stalin was appointed a
political commissar and put in charge of
the defense of the city of Saracen this
is the city that would ultimately become
Stalingrad he frequently clashed with
Trotsky who had been appointed his
military superior he once imprisoned a
group of Trotsky supporters on a leaky
barge and left them to drown the
Bolsheviks at this point changed their
name to the Russian Communist Party
Stalin's rise through this groups ranks
was impressive and he owed it all to the
support of Lenin in 1922 Lenin made him
general secretary of the communist
party's Central Committee opposed he
held for the rest of his life but within
a year Stalin had fallen out with Lenin
Georgia Stalin's home state had been
promised autonomy at the time of the
revolution but that promise had been
reneged on between 1918 and 1921
ittan enjoyed a period of self-rule but
in 1922 Lenin decided to bring its back
into the fold
he wanted the reunion to be a peaceful
one but Stalin he had other ideas he
cracked down hard having the leaders of
the Georgian rebellion executed and
Lenin at this point he was absolutely
furious but in late 1922 he suffered the
first of a series of strokes which
severely impacted his ability to command
in a testaments which was published in
November he castigated Stalin Stalin is
too rude this defect becomes intolerable
in a secretary-general that is why I
suggest the comrades think of a way of
removing Stalin from their post and
appointing another man in his stead
months later while Lenin was still
hospitalized
Stalin phoned an ins wife who he
suspected of feeding her husband's
dislike of him and subjected her to an
avalanche of abuse referring to her in
the conversation as a syphilitic whore
when Lenin found out about this he was
unsurprisingly outraged
many people actually believe the stress
of the situation precipitated Lenin's
death about 10 months later after
Lenin's death Stalin took the lead in
organizing the funeral
appearing as the chief pallbearer it was
at this point that he initiated the
deification of Lenin even renaming
Petrograd as Leningrad Stalin used this
opportunity to reinvent himself as the
bearer of Lenin's legacy from now on to
doubt Stalin was to doubt Lenin Stalin's
main rival was now Leon Trotsky and his
followers the leftist Trotskyites in
1925 Stalin forced Trotsky to resign as
people's commissar for war from now on
anyone who spoke out against the
secretary-general were risking their
very lives when open opposition broke
out in late 1927 it's fermenters
including Trotsky were expelled from the
party
Trotsky he was exiled to Kazakhstan in
1919 Stalin married his second wife
nadezhda they had two children Vasily
born in 1921 and Svetlana born in 1926
on the evening of November the 8th 1932
the couple were hosting a party to
celebrate the 15th anniversary of the
October Revolution they often argued in
this occasion it was no different
nadezhda accused her husbands of being
inconsiderate towards her he responded
by humiliating her in front of their
guests he flicked cigarettes at her and
addressed her as hey you the following
morning servants found the dead two dead
of a gunshot wound to the head during
the Russian Civil War Lenin a daughter
of the acquisition of the peasants grain
and livestock 85% of the soviet
population they lived off the land he
had also ordered the collectivization of
farms peasants perceived as better off
the cool acts were to be destroyed
killed or deported these measures caused
widespread devastation and eventually
famine
realizing his mistake Lenin in 1921
introduced a new economic policy to try
to improve the situation
however in 1928 Stalin decided to
reintroduce collectivization he aims to
achieve this within five years anyone
who was resisted was simply put to death
in December of 1929 Stalin announced the
liquidation of the kulaks as a class
poorer peasants were encouraged to
denounce the cool acts who were to be
shot on sight or if they were lucky
deported to gulags in Siberia Stalin
sent out armed forces into the
countryside to force villagers into
collectives many of the people had no
knowledge of agriculture the cool acts
resorted to slaughtering their own
cattle and destroying their own
equipment rather than see it disappear
into the hands of the state terrible
famine then ensued in Ukraine it was the
worst with up to ten million people
dying this time was to be remembered as
the killing of hunger yet the state
offered no help in fact anyone caught
with so much as a handful of grain was
liable to punishment by death at the
same time as his people were starving to
death Stalin exported millions of tons
of vitally needed grain in 1931 Stalin
stated that the Soviet Union was a
hundred years behind other countries
technologically they had ten years to
catch up or they would be crushed by the
rest of the world his five-year plan saw
the birth of new industrial cities
within a decade the Soviet Union had
indeed surpassed all nations in terms of
industrial developments with the
exception of the United States but
ordinary Russians they fell may benefit
from Stalin's successes factory workers
became fixated on meeting increasingly
unrealistic targets if they failed they
risked the harshest of punishments by
1935 a million citizens were residing in
Stalin's forced labour camps the gulags
at the 1934 political congress a threat
to Stalin's absolute power emerged in
the form of leningrad party boss
Sergei Kirov Stalin reacted with a
fierce purge of the party that saw 1108
that's 56% of the Congress delegates
arrested and 1/3 of them executed
on September the 1st 1934 Sergei Kirov
was assassinated outside the party
officers in Leningrad the alleged
assassin his wife and 85 year old mother
all quickly put to death though many
people believe that Stalin himself was
behind this assassination Stalin seized
upon this assassination as the catalyst
for the great terror he brought in a new
law which deprived defendants of any
defense a number of Moscow show trials
were held nearly all of them resulting
in the death penalty over the next three
years up to 1939 Stalin's purges became
increasingly severe he did this very
methodically drawing up arrest quotas
along with numbers to be shot in each
district still over the fulfilment of
this was encouraged people terrified of
being denounced got in with their
denunciations first before they too were
denounced this led to the gulag scene
being overcrowded and new complexes had
to be built by slave labor no one except
for Stalin himself could truly sleep in
peace many of those in positions of
power became terrified that they too
would be next with some of them
committing suicide in order to escape
their fate the military were not immune
to the purges either at the same time
that Hitler was taking over Austria
Stalin was ordering the execution of his
most able military leaders those who
survived then became paranoid of one
another during 1939 as Hitler's military
muscle-flexing pushed Europe towards war
Stalin feared for the safety of his
country he looked to Great Britain as a
potential ally but Britain didn't appear
to be doing much of anything at all
so when approached by Germany Stalin
didn't hesitate he signed a
non-aggression pact with Hitler it
declared simply that the Russian and
German people would not take up arms
against each other this took a great
deal of pressure off Stalin
in the summer of 1940 Hitler's
subjugation of Europe seemed unstoppable
in less than two weeks is blitzkrieg
Panzer armies had rolled through Belgium
Holland and France and at this point he
began looking to the east
Stalin however couldn't believe that the
Fuhrer would go back on his word
but On June the 22nd 1941 this is
exactly what happens Nazi troops crossed
the Polish border and invaded the Soviet
Union the Soviet leader was caught
totally off-guard
within a month German troops were a
hundred miles from Leningrad Smolensk
fell on July the 16th and by June the
26th just four days after the attack had
begun 400,000 Soviet soldiers were
trapped as the German pincers enclosed
round Minsk a key stronghold on route to
Moscow On June the 29th reports reached
Moscow that the city of Minsk could
fallen it was only a week since the
German invasion had begun at this rate
the Germans expected to be in Moscow
within a month it was at this point that
Stalin seemed to finally grasp the
enormity of the disaster he raged at his
generals even reducing the stolid head
of the army Zhukov to tears but then
Stalin crumbled he groans everything's
lost I give up
Lenin founded our state and we've
screwed it up Stalin was driven to his
doctor on the outskirts of Moscow there
he slumped in shock in his armchair the
next day he didn't come into the Kremlin
or respond to phone calls in his absence
no one dared to make any decisions or
sign any documents
suddenly there was a chilling vacuum at
the heart of power historians are
divided on Stalin's mindset during this
time some believe that he was playing a
dangerous game with his inner circle
watching and waiting to see who would
try to seize the reins during this time
of crisis others are of the opinion that
he came close to a nervous breakdown
what Stalin faced was not just military
defeat but the collapse of everything
that he had worked for within Russia
finally on June the 30th the politbureau
drove out to Stalin's dacha they found
him still sitting in his armchair he
looked up at them Haggard and nervous
and he asked why have you come he
suspected a coup but the Politburo did
not want to overthrow Stalin they wanted
him to return to the Kremlin and take
charge of the state Defence Committee
the Soviet War Cabinet a relieved Stalin
perhaps that his most vulnerable ever
asked can I lead the country to victory
there may be more deserving candidates
the reply though it came quickly there
is none more worthy nodding Stalin
accepted his new role and he began to
regain his nerve Kiev was overrun by
September
Stalin's advisers had begged him to
evacuate the doomed city however he
refused and more than half a million
people were either killed or taken
prisoner searching for a scapegoat
Stalin blamed the prisoners themselves
all prisoners of war he declared were
traitors those who returned after the
war were sent directly to labor camps
when his son by his first marriage Yakov
was taken prisoner the Nazis approached
Stalin about trading him for some of
their own Stalin simply replied but he
had no son by that name Yakov was shot
and killed by October the Germans were
perilously close to Moscow the
government moved 500 miles away but
Stalin he decided to stay attempting a
parade on Red Square on November the 7th
the tanks drove past him and onto the
front lines just 25 miles outside of the
city the Soviet troops fought valiantly
and the Russian winter began to cripple
the German forces in the ends the Nazis
were unable to solidify their gains and
they were steadily beaten back Stalin
also wisely teamed up with the Allies
when Stalin Churchill and Roosevelt met
at the Tehran conference in 1943 Joseph
Stalin was reintroduced to the West as
kindly Uncle Joe by 1945 the Soviets had
won the war but at the cost it was
enormous more than 25 million Soviets
had died six times as many as in Germany
Stalin vowed that he would never let
Russia be this vulnerable again at the
Yalta Conference in 1945 the Allies met
to discuss the post-war world Stalin
made it clear that Eastern Europe was to
remain under his control Britain in the
USA however were not happy with Stalin's
actions in Eastern Europe Winston
Churchill famously declared that an Iron
Curtain had descended across the
continent and with that the Cold War
began
back home Stalin was even more popular
than before grateful Russians hoped that
the great victory over Hitler would
sweep clean the misery of the past
unfortunately however the war had merely
distracted not changed Joseph Stalin
even though the crowds adored him he was
convinced that everyone was out to get
him
thousands of returning soldiers were
sent to labor camps many Jewish
intellectuals and doctors were tried and
killed on Stalin's 70th birthday in 1949
images of the great leader were
projected into the skies over Moscow his
all-seeing eye was omnipresent but the
ravages of old age were beginning to
catch up with him after a great feast On
February 28 to 1953 Joseph Stalin had a
paralyzing stroke over the next few days
he slowly suffocated to death Joseph
Stalin died on the morning of March the
fifth 1953 his funeral was an orgy of
grief Soviet simply couldn't imagine
going on without their God and Father
but go on they did three years after
Stalin's death is eventual replacements
Nikita Khrushchev gave an extraordinary
speech at a closed session of the 20th
Party Congress he said that while Stalin
had been a great leader he had also
committed terrible crimes against the
Soviet people the myth of the
benevolence protective comrade leader
was finally revealed for what it
actually was a terrible lie so I really
hope you enjoyed that episode of
biographic s-- if you did there's a
couple of things you could do right now
one is hit that like button below also
if you want more stuff like this we put
our brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
where we put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching